ونحييكم من جديد نظام الحكم في ايران يعرف
بالنظام المغلق والمعقد الذي يرتكز بشكل
اساسي
بيدي اعلى سلطه في البلاد وهي سلطه المرشد
الاعلى الذي يمتلك كافه صلاحيات ويحدد
سياسه البلاد وهو القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الايرانيه ويسيطر على الاجهزه
الامنيه المرشد هو من يختار رؤساء القضاء
والجيش والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وبيده قرار اعلان الحرب والسلبه اما سلطه
التنفيذيه فهي بيد رئيس الذي يعتبر ثاني
سلطه بعد المرشد وهو المسؤول عن تنفيذ
الدستور ينتخب الرئيس لمده اربع سنوات ولا
يمكنه ان يخدم اكثر من فترتين متتاليتين
وفي ايران ايضا مجلس خبراء القياده وهي
هيئه تضم 88 عضوا من رجال الدين مهمه
المجلس اختيار المرشد ومراجعه عمله واذا
اعتبر غير قادر اي المرشد على اداء
الواجباته فلدا هذا المجلس سلطه عزله
وهناك ايضا مجلس الصيانه الدستور وهي هيئه
لتنفيذ الدستور تتكون من 12 عضوا تتولى
الموافقه على جميع مشاريع القوانين التي
يوقرها البرلمان وله سلطه الاعتراض عليها
كما يمكنه منع المرشحين من خوض انتخابات
البرلمان والرئاسه ومجلس خبراء القياده
اما البرلمان فهو يتكون من 290 عضوانيه
انتخابهم عن طريق التصويت الشعبي كل اربعه
سنوات يتمتع البرلمان بسلطه اصدار
القوانين واستدعاء الوزراء والرئيس وعزلهم
لكن في المقابل يجب ان يوافق مجلس صيانه
الدستور على جميع القوانين التي يوقرها
البرلمان المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه في
ايران تتمثل بالقوات المسلحه التي تتالف
من الجيش والحرس الثوري الذي يعد قوه
رئيسيه عسكريا وسياسيا واقتصاديا كذلك في
ايران وذلك للعلاقات الوثيقه التي تربط
الحرس الثوري بالمرشد
تصدير الثوره ماذا يعني اجراءات من قبل
حكومه تعتبر نفسها ثوريه
تهدف للترويج لثورات مماثله في المناطق
غير المحكومه داخل حدودها او في بلدان
اخرى
ظهر مصطلح تصدير الثوره في ايران قبل تمكن
الخميني من قلب النظام الملكي لتصبح ايران
دوله دينيه
تصدير ثوره كان من اولويات النظام
الايراني رغم الازمه الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
اربعون عاما وايران تسعى الى تصدير ثورتها
تمد نفوذها الى محيطها الاقليمي
اعد من جديد الى ضيوفي من الشرقيه كامل
الخطيه الكاتب والبحث السعودي من بيروت
مصطفى فحص الكاتب الصحفي ومن دبي مسعود
الفاكهه البحث في شان الايراني اهلا بكم
من جديد استاذ كامل لما نتحدث عن المؤسسات
المؤسسات الحكم في ايران نتحدث عن مؤسسات
مرتبطه بالطابع الديني المتشدد مش حتى
مرتبطه هي ربما يمكن القول منبثقه او حتى
تاسست عبر هذا الموروث الديني هذه
المؤسسات
واليوم ايران تود ان تنخرط في مسار طبيعي
ان صح التعبير يمكن ان يتوافق مع رؤيه
المجتمع الدولي هذه المؤسسات ما مستقبلها
بحسب قراءتك بعد هذه الاتفاقيه
طبعا هذه المؤسسات من ضمن مهامها هي لها
مهام كثيره بالتاكيد هي مش مؤسسات شكليه
بس من ضمن مهامها انه تضمن استمرار النظام
في حال غياب شخصيات المؤثره قادره على
انتاج قياده النظام بالذات المرشد بشكل
رئيسي
فالمؤسسات هي مش يعني لما نقول كلمه
مؤسسات للعموم في الادب في الادبيات
العلوم السياسيه كلمه مؤسسه كلمه ايجابيه
لكن في حاله ايران كلمه المؤسسات او
المؤسسات الموجوده في الطيران هي للحفاظ
زي ما تفضلتي على طبيعه النظام الدينيه
على الانتاج قيادات قائمه على ذات المفهوم
اللي
بناء عليها تصدر
قلب القائد الخميني ثوره ضد النظام الشيعه
انقلب وتولاه هو رجال الدين برجع مره
ثانيه على قصه المدنيه والنزول
هذه هي في العراق رجل الدين رجل الدين يظل
حاكم بسلطه غيبيه هي المعضله الوجوديه
ايران لا تحول لشريك كامل للشراكه شريك
قوي وساهم في التنميه يساهم باستدامه
الامن والسلام والتعارف المنطقه عليه انه
يتخلص من هذه السلطه لانه يتخلص من هذه
الفكره يتخلص من هذه لان هذه النظريه تعني
مما تعني بانهم ممهدون لظهور الامام
النظريه القائمه عليها الدوله وان هم
مرحله انتقاليه فقط غير هم لا يدعون لهم
في السهم وانما يحملون رايه تدعوه الى
القائم المعالي محمد يمهدون طريق نحو
ظهوره
فهنا يعني الان احنا نفرح ونتفائل لما
تنخطب بنسبه التوتر الاقليم لانه احنا
مهنيين باستقلال الاقليم كقوه بقوه تسعه
الى التنميه تسعه
طبعا التنميه ما تظل يعني ما تزدهر الا في
حالات السلام المستقر لا شك انه نطرح بهذه
الخطوات لا شك انه نامل بانه ايران بدل ان
تتعرض الى ثوره وثوره تدحرج نيرانها
ومشاكلها نحو الاقليم نتمنى انه النظام في
ايران قادر على انه يقوي الذات ذاته داخل
بشكل متدرج لكن سريع ايضا ما في دول للابد
ولا في دول الجوار تنتظر كل فتره لما يصعد
تيار ما يصير اقوى من الاخر والله مره
ثانيه النظام في ايراني يقلق مين يقلق
بالذات لان ايضا اطلاقا للجوار هو اخلاق
سياسي مش مجرد مسلك مشاغب يقلق مين يقلق
الدول الا فيها اقليات شيعيه عربيه بالذات
يبدا يقلقها على اساس يحول هل الاقليات
العربيه الى اوراق مساواه
بالضبط استاذ كامل هو لهذا السبب بتحديد
طرحنا فكره مدى امكانيه ان تتخلص ايران في
هذه المرحله من هذه المؤسسات حضرتك ربما
يعني تقول بانه بعضها لا يمكن تسميته
بالمؤسسات ولكن هذه المكونات داخل النظام
الايراني تحدثت على
هذه الخطوره في امكانيه ان تستمر هذه
المجموعات انقل لك هذه النقطه استاذ مسعود
استاذ مسعود هذه المجموعات لطالما خدمت
النظام الايراني وحضرتك تعلم بانها ضغطت
من خلالها على ملفات عديده ما مصيرها ما
مستقبلها بعد هذه الاتفاقيه هل يمكن
لايران ان تتمسك بيمينها بهذه الاتفاقيه
وان تترك بيسارها هذه المجموعات التي كانت
تمثل خطر على المنطقه
علينا ان نؤكد على مساله مهمه في هذا
الاتفاق بانه نحن في مرحله اختبار في
الوقت الحاضر
ومصداقيه الطرفين
تظهر خلال هذه الفتره وخاصه الطرف
الايراني هو الطرف الذي دائما كان
كانت موجهه اليه اصابع الاتهام
دعم الميليشيات وخاصه بالنسبه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه الحوثيين هذه مساله
تعتبر
مهمه واستراتيجيه في هذا الاتفاق باعتقادي
هنا المحك ايران بغض النظر عن تعدديه
المؤسسات بالنهايه الدول لا يهمها تعدديه
هذه المؤسسات وطريقه ارتباطها ببعض تريد
المحصله تظهر في السياسه الخارجيه
الملموسه لايران والعالم لا يحكم من هذا
القرار الا انه هذا القرار علينا الى جانب
ذلك ان نشير تم اتخاذه من قبل المجلس
الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني ومن سكرتير
مجلس الامن الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
علي شامخاني هو قانونيا لا يحق له التصويت
في في هذا المجلس الا انه له صفه اضافيه
الى كونه المجلس على الامن القومي وهو
ممثل المرشد الاعلى في المجلس الاعلى
للامن القومي وفي هذه الحاله يكسب قوته من
من المرشد الاعلى وجميع السياسات الخارجيه
الايرانيه
الاستراتيجيه والسياديه في واقع الامر يجب
على المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
ان يصادق عليها اي المرشد الاعلى هو الذي
يصادق على هذه القرارات لذا
هذه هذا الاتفاق مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في واقع العام هو اتفاق اعلى
سلطه في البلاد وهو المرشد الاعلى من خلال
نوابه في هذا المجلس اتخذوا هذا القرار
وعلي شمخاني يمثل المرشد في واقع الامر
ولا يمثل الحكومه لذا القرار اتخذ من اعلى
السلطات في ايران لا يمكن لها في المستقبل
ان تلقي اللوم على جهه اخرى بل المسؤول
سيكون المرشد الاعلى في هذه الحاله
باعتقادي اتخاذ هذا القرار وايضا توقيع
الاتفاق في دوله بامكانها ان تكون ضامنه
وليس في العراق مع كل احتراما للعراق وليس
في سلطنه عمان صحيح
صحيح هناك خصوصيه للصين وقادره ان تكون
وسيط برتبه ضامن يقول البعض
وضحت الفكره ولكن استاذه مصطفى استك تفضل
به استاذ مسعود لانه هو وكانه ربط بين ما
يحدث الان وبين هذه الاتفاقيات وبينما يجب
ان يكون عليه النظام الايراني حتى تنجح
هذه الاتفاقيه منذ قليل حضرتك تحدثت عن
فيلق القدس واضيف الحرس الثوري واضيف كل
ما في الداخل الايراني من
مجموعات
لا نعلم ان هي قادره في فتره من الفترات
ان تتخلى عنها هذا كذلك سؤال يبقى مطروح
الاستاذ مسعود منذ قليل قال بانه وكان
التخلي عن هذه المجموعات يمكن ان يكون
خطوه لبناء ثقه امتن بين الاطراف ما رايك
عدنا الى عدنا الى المعضل مقاله استاذ
مسعود دقيق وحساس ان راس الهرم السلطه هو
الذي اعطى
الامر في علي شامخاني لعلي شامخاني لكي
يوقع بصفته ممثلا ااا ممثلا له ولكن انا
ساضيف واتساءل مع استاذ مسعود
هل قوه البيت المرشد كما كانت في السابق
هي قادره على احتواء
الاطراف الداخليه التي قد تعترض بعض في
بعض الامور في بعض
المواضيع ببعض لديها حساسيات تجاه البنود
بعض الاتفاق في المستقبل واضافه نعود الى
افتراضي الموت المفاجئ للمرشد من سيسيطر
على السلطه وكيف ستوحكم في الداخل والخارج
مشروعيه من سيعود الى السلطه او في
المرحله الانتقاليه مشروعيه ثوريه لا
تكتمل الا من خلال الخارج وهذا الاتفاق
عطل الخارج لان المشروعيه في الداخل
مضروبه لو قمنا بالاستفتاء حقيقه 90% من
الشعب الايراني ضد النظام
بدون مبالغه الخارج هو الشرعيه الثوريه
طيب نعود لسؤالي الذي قطعتيه عنه هو الحرس
الثوري فيلق القدس تصدير الثوره كيف كيف
يمكن لهذه المؤسسات ان تجد نفسها عاطله عن
العمل صباحا عند عند في اليوم الذي يتم
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين
هل لدى بيت المرشد في الفتره لهذه
الانتقاليه
السيطره الكامله على كافه مراكز صنع
القرار داخل الكيان الواحد المحافظ انا
شخصيا لدي الشكوك استاذ مصطفى حاول ان
تجبنا عن هذا السؤال سؤال
يطرح في هذه الاثناء حضرتك طرحته ولكن
بحسب قراءتك لوضع المرشد لمكانه المرشد
للخلافات في البيت الايراني هل يمكن تحقيق
ذلك فعليا لديك شكوك ولكن تتجه الى اين
احتمال وليس وليس يعني احد الاحتمالات
وليس احتمالا وحيدا يعني او انه هناك رؤيه
واحده احتمال ان هناك صراعه في ايران على
السلطه داخل البيت الواحد هذا يطرح فكره
اخرى ان هذه الاحتجاجات والمعارضه التي
تتشكل في الداخل
لعب بيوت المؤسسه للثوره يعني بيت راس
جاني بيت مر حسين موسوي بيت الخميني وبيت
المنتظر بما لديهم من امتدادات اضافه الى
الاحتجاجات وبقايا الحركه الخضراء والتيار
الجديد ما بعد الاصلاحي هذه كلها امام
معضله حقيقيه في المستقبل كيف كيف سيكون
شكل النظام الايراني ما بعد المرشد مباشره
حتى لو استطاع هذا البيت بيت المرشد انتاج
مرشد اخر ولكن الجميع يعلم المرشد الجديد
لا يملك شرعيه ثوريه
هذا المرشد السيد علي خميره هو اخر
الشرعيات الثوريه المرشد الجديد هو مرشد
معين هناك قوه اقوى منه وايضا قوه شعبيه
رافضه له فاذا ايران الداخل في معضله هذا
يطرح السؤال ليس فقط على الاتفاق يطرح
السؤال على طبيعه على طبيعه وشكل النظام
الايراني ما بعد المرشد صحيح وهنا كذلك
عوامل اخرى ربما يطرح البعض هي العوامل
الاقتصاديه الى اي مدى هذه العوامل
الاقتصاديه الى
ساعود لك بعض بعض فاصل بعد فاصل انا لا
اود مقاطعتك ابدا ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
ساعود لك للاستاذ مسعود وكذلك سابدا معك
استاذ كامل حول هذه العوامل ان كانت قادره
ان تدفع
ان يقف داخل ايراني صف واحد لانجاح هذه
الاتفاقيه بعد قليل